those your two la classe very good very
good all right
today I prepared you for French with the
obvious opening the Queens gambit
declined triggering variation or as my
comer would call it II 45 either way
the much more obscured Sugaree Lopez
which I've also played which is even
worse now this is worse okay so I'm
lecturing on the middle game because I
was told to also I like leading leading
I like reading your great comments on
the internet about my lectures so keep
sending those those are hilarious right
it really shows how intelligent my
audience is okay although Julian claimed
you guys were less intelligent that's
that's a big fight you got in your hands
so today is a very special day because
there's three members of members there's
three employees of the Chess Club we
have birthdays today so hopefully not
the same parents though but and also
today's the day the Cubs start to win
the World Series as predicted in your
favorite movie yeah exactly
although prediction was a little
suspicious okay anyway we're going to
look at a position that's unusual
because probably blacks already made two
mistakes but you know it's like move ten
so that's less mistakes than you at home
usually make my move ten ten yeah okay
and this is a game I played against Adam
Leaf in the US Junior Championship
before your great-grandmother was born
okay Lulu just walked in so we're going
to start the lecture over even though
it's being recorded please close the
door
thank you alright so when I play the US
Junior Championship you know back in the
day that was the most fun tournament
ever I was even sillier then and I
always wondered when I played Adam lief
if I wrote a letter to his family if I
would write the leaves because I don't
think you hear right the Leafs that
doesn't make any sense you can be
talking my Kummer the English major over
here Mike
we're okay so we we played a chigorin
now the line I'm going to look at today
starts with Knight f3 and then this line
okay now in this position if you're a
good player then you play the movie six
and this is seen in many Grandmaster
games but I never claimed to be a good
player so I play e5 in this position if
you're a good player you play Queen to
d6 as in many Kasparov semi Slav games
your two favorite players okay they
played a match what year what candidate
what year they play candidates match
anyone eighty something is correct okay
and I actually played in the final so
whoever won that match played Karpov for
the World Championship it could have
been Smith Slav Karpov okay
now Smith Slav got the consolation prize
he did lose the match to Kasparov but
unlike Apsara he attended my first
wedding so if you could pick to win a
candidates man should be the world
champion or attend my first wedding guy
flips a coin some people did both like
Nigel shortly he lost the World
Championship man okay so everybody plays
Queen b6 here because it's obvious chief
of the most dim-witted individual with
an advanced degree in hyperbolic
topology that this pawn is better than
this point so I play e takes d4 because
that's what I do
although I'm certain Queen d6 as a
better move okay and then he takes
getting rid of this stupid pawn and I
play nine g7 this is actually the
starting position of our lecture today
unfortunately HBO didn't have enough
money to pay me for a whole hour
so we're done drop the mic and I have to
walk away
you know Chapelle show you I'm talking
about okay good you got it yeah as long
as one in a million gets that that's the
David Miller what's his name Dennis
Miller ratio nice can you edit that okay
good
what you got to edit my lectures dude
you don't edit when my cameras up here
and you come up here for an hour fixing
it you don't edit that it's just you up
there fixing it that's the whole lecture
okay
all right now in this position white has
an obvious advantage might come er
what's the obvious white advantage to of
this chefs
I mean if Ken West was here would had a
funny answer oh well but white has the
two bishops better than the two knights
although this opening is named after
what famous Russian Grandmaster goal
that's correct now I'm not going to go
out on a limb and ask him to Gordon's
first name because that's not going to
work out well but we'll ask Julian here
of course yeah okay same as Bhavana
canned tall maybe okay
now the advantage is that black has
blacks pawns are pretty sweet all
together
nothing doubled nothing isolated all of
whites pawns are doubled and tripled in
quadrupled and salchow isolated horrible
as my common would say unfortunately for
black white has a lot of Center pawns
and black has zero on the other hand I
can castle either way and you can't
castle at all and I have all my minor
pieces I only have one this one not that
one okay but I think Bishop f4 was
developed it's on f1 yes
okay now this game was played 97 I
remember winning a long end game where I
was worse most of the game one thing I
like about this opening is that if
you're worse it doesn't matter it's too
complicated so people just sit there
confused and their flag falls as in my
game with Anatoly Lane from a thousand
years ago where he lost on time and said
they're confused okay so he played
Bishop e2 developing his bishop terrible
a Bishop e2 is okay now in this in this
opening black King Castle either way I
usually prefer castling queenside so I
did Queen to b3 normally the endgame
will favor white because if you have
doubled pawns and isolated pawns and
your king is on e one your King might
get in trouble in the endgame your King
will get in trouble okay I played rookie
a I'll look how good - I'm so well
developed here
I'm the best okay rugby one now I almost
played the move Queen d7 because I
figured in about 30 years
Ken West would recommend it okay but
then I was like wait a minute I've never
met Ken west I know who that is so then
I changed my mind okay but I did touch
my queen so I had to move my Queen Queen
d7 not a good move right my comer
because of checkmate the only move
allowing checked me ken west recommended
man stuff when you're not here X clam
once again corrected by the audience who
always can figure out how to hang meat
in one much better than I can
I mean I didn't see King V it's too good
okay
my touch my queen so Queen takes Queen
now we're going to vote you can vote it
home okay so here's what I want you to
do okay I want you to pretend you're
here what you're already doing and get
it right down and then see how you did
I'll wait buggery up okay now we're
going to vote did white take with a pawn
or with the rook
who says with the pawn okay hold on hey
seven people at home and who says with
the rook and as per usual the entire
class is wrong shocking but you at home
were right because you wrote down both
hands that's not what you did he took
with a pawn now generally you want your
puns to come closer together although
it's very strange to what you look on
the B file then take with the pawn
perhaps you wanted to play b4 b5 Julian
with some crazy comment
yeah but then you're a pons week I think
the moves are similar I just wanted the
class to be wrong all right okay yeah
that's about the same
okay Knight to g6 that'll show him
sometimes white plays rook g1 and takes
my G pod and that's how I had too much
to drink but Knight g6 none of that will
happen
King f1 otherwise I could play four
tricks tricks that don't exist but I
would still play for them
for example f4 night takes f4 Knight
takes d4 what should white play you this
should be three check takes takes who's
better here now probably draw right you
yeah but white has the wrong colored
rook polish I'm sure you were thinking
of yeah you think White's better yeah
rooks no good you're just going by all
my theories I didn't have these threes
in 1987 so I don't know who's better
okay so white stopped all of that by
playing King f1 no pinning okay so I
played f5 and I want to play f4 but he
beat me to it darn well though I teach a
lot of kids classes and taking this way
is pretty common so giving black a nice
advantage all right you're going to
learn that on Thursday Lulu you'll be
like what what are you doing exactly
yeah they'll never stop that okay now we
have sort of a blocked position which is
good for the bishops of the Knights the
ninth right
and also my pieces are all good computer
of course likes white because white has
two bishops also White's better right
okay King b8 as you recommended earlier
rep g1 I played route g6 a lot of this
opening there's not a lot of us we play
route d6 a lot okay
but in this hoping my jeep ones going
immediately so I have Rick d6 okay Rick
g5 but I saw it defending the
offending boring rook g8 so my knight on
g6 can move and efore so as Popeye would
say he was a fine chess player he had
all he could stands against tens no more
we moved around and around and around
and he was bored and he played efore
normally that would be a bad move
because I'm going to take all of his
pawns but the computer likes it because
his bishops get very active and he opens
the position now unfortunately Ken West
isn't here so nobody will suggest pawn
takes pawn which hangs the knight on d5
right Danny okay so I played Knight
takes f4 he played Bishop c4 attacking
my rook I saw it and then II five so
he's pushing his pawns forward he's
sacrificing a pawn but he's going to win
it back and now he has the past a pawn
however with the isolated pawns the weak
d4 pawn the complicated King position
where both of us can get mated it's too
early to tell what's going to happen and
the computer eventually says the
position is equal and he does win his
pawn back but at what price
rook h6 I noticed often in the chigorin
my rook is moving sideways along the
third-ranked doesn't happen other
openings too often King g1 defending now
again Ken West isn't here so I can't
explain that 92 fails to bishop takes
but I would if he was here so I played
c6 getting a little left walking the d4
pawn bishop f1 obviously the right move
I played rook d8 attacking the D pawn
the problem is when you push all of your
pawns your opponent might take them it's
hard to defend the d4 pawn especially
with a pawn okay rook f7 attacking my
pawn like I'm nobody
rook g6 check if only ken west is yours
I could ask them what white would play
here but it will be insulting to anybody
you well honor by that let's Rick if
they check
okay so if you're confused at home saw
my king h1 put it in H rook g8 and lose
like wait a minute
Rick g1 maid is the threat that's what
she was thinking yeah okay
so he decided not to get mated h3 put it
in H now again I'm not claiming the
black wins with the chigorin in fact
blacks probably losing that's not my
point
I'm not the one on trial here the point
is that you're Gorn is very complicated
and it's not like a lot of openings
where White's a little better then they
agree to a drawn 30 moves both sides
have winning chances and it's easy to
make a mistake and throughout the game
the computer said that White's better
but you can see black has good chances
rook check again insert Ken West joke
here King H to 9 to d3 as I was playing
the game over I thought Knight six h3
was really cool yeah but I was 97 what
do I know
yeah but Knight g3 is probably better I
don't know why not why what do what's
wrong 93 how could you after 96 h3 can
you take with the bishop and get six
Queens you know take on f5h 7067 that
could be dangerous
yeah who rigged e1 yeah I don't know
you're a little slow over there yeah
he's 67 s fast it's fast yeah alright so
93 DoubleX clam not sure why you can't
take it okay rook a one night f2 let's
see who can I ask you what's the threat
what's black threatening
know what's black threatening hmm who
you know uh you you never know yeah rook
h1 meet with advantage yeah okay so he
played a little sugar me do rook f8
check yeah tricky right yeah okay
everybody's happy
blacks applaud up computer says it's
equal okay that happens a six never do
anything I learned early yeah okay and
eventually because I was upon up in the
endgame I won with my extra pawn plus
two pawns yeah now I'm three pawns up
and mate with advantage then the kings
go in the middle confusing everybody you
what's the crazy comment a6 you me not
move five of that game we looked at
today well this is a different game yeah
okay
so in that game we got a very complex
position where either side could have
had the advantage and computer likes why
and then it didn't and that's the good
thing about the chigorin is if you play
the chigorin often you'll have more
games than your opponent who's facing
all kinds of nonsense usually not that
you're going usually something else okay
now for all you people in the
Netherlands watching this game was
played in the Netherlands so now okay
now somebody tried to correct me telling
me where Belgium and the Netherlands was
they're both on the earth okay I lived
in Belgium for four years before you
were born so they moved a little bit it
used to be the countries lined up now
they moved to differently okay do they
believe me they don't know shh don't
tell him okay so this is a game I was
black in the Netherlands against the
Dutch player okay and this whoa that's
bad right
yeah oh this is the other thing that's
the other thing he was doing I thought
it was my thing yeah okay so this is the
this is the same opening with all the
same mistakes and this is 1991 and so
after that spit-take white played Bishop
e2 which we saw earlier it was about 10
minutes ago
and what did I do 10 minutes ago you and
what did I do here yeah I plug asla
queenside yeah
that's how I roll okay Queen b3 looking
familiar yeah rook 88 and he Castle
queenside he showed me very confusing
but again if you're going to trade
Queens your Kings not so exposed until
the next game when we don't trade Queens
I hope we can here that was pretty close
to the mic okay
f5 as in the previous game Bishop c3
King bee it is in the previous game
takes I wonder which way took this time
should we vote again this time you have
a better chance of being right all right
Knight d5 King bee - yeah
rook g6 as in the previous game so the
previous game white got his pawns going
but ended up sacrificing upon doing so
here white has nothing he can't get his
pawns going Rep g1 as in the previous
game but without Ricky 1 Rick h6 rook h1
a brilliant maneuver rook e1 to g1 to h1
never do anything you is some crazy
comment horrible I actually think it is
horrible yeah well you miss something
obviously rook takes h2 and that's what
you missed
you still don't see it aren't you like
2800 he has a knight takes e3 good looks
good
alright so we were analyzing the
following variation and I thought 93 was
good and white loses everything so draw
probably but good for black
like he probably read they have black
here yeah yeah cuz I don't know what I
do cry link crying was moving more sense
okay
so I assume when I when he played rook
g1 and he thought I would play here he
was gonna do something like that he's
like alright rook there okay
hey what happened I why what's going on
okay rook h3 stopping his each pawn for
moving okay anyway I played rook h3 now
his rook is tied down to his pawn so
that's good for him Bishop e1
recommended by Julian a six never do
anything that gives me lift the ship f1
forcing my rope to retreat rook takes f3
looks risky it's not risky oh is risky
yeah I didn't do that yeah okay all the
way back and back to d6 yes see we're
good you guys would hope you like naked
moves we move our work back and forth so
the starting position and my opponent
does the same okay once you can do that
you too will be a grandmaster probably
like rap or something okay rook g1 again
g6 solid Bishop g2 why did my opponent
play Bishop g2 instead of somewhere else
he doesn't what I you with the right
answer I was going to say e4 and crush
me but either ones good because I think
I'm right I don't think he wants to play
off for I think he wants to play Eve or
and then do this okay what's approved
without usually he's like that okay
don't sue me Donkey Kong alright you
know my brother's gonna Donkey Kong did
you know that well now you know it did
you forget
I mean if you forgotten in the last five
seconds yeah cuz I'm used to these
people so you know yeah I asked the guy
what's the right move and he's like did
you did it and I was like what okay so I
played night before but I won't tell you
which one night see ya Bishop f1 always
played this ship f1 right rook c6
yeah I'm threatening to check him my
comer approved Bishop c4 high and you
made fun of you when I played a6
I saw you making fun of me now it all
comes to fruition okay now White has
lost his most important of advantages
the two bishops also he's left with a
bishop on D - yeah okay rook c1 always
trade King b7 King b6 advancing my king
in the ending like you guys always do a
5 B 4 look at me advanced age 3 terrible
okay and this is the game where I make
one of my favorite moves after E for I
played ninety seven thousand of my
favorite moves I like them what's blacks
next to move
you see 5r are ya okay rook c1 rook da
are threatening discovered everything
although not really but it does stop a5
I guarantee it because then I go here
yay
and then white has a good pun structure
if you're at home I'm just kidding
correct
also what all right Bishop g5 yeah I
blame you okay Bishop g5 rook a8 ready
to Queen on the queenside
c5 as recommended by Julian rook g8
again and here I come
Rick see a knight FA recommended by
which Danish Grandmaster no nothing over
here Ben Larson he was by his Danish as
I am was in South America the last 60
years of his life okay
ah he is born in Denmark alright rookie
196 and it's over I have a majority his
majority is a joke now this is my
favorite move of the game only Julian
can find it
I played Knight c5 attacking b3 and he
played 'if I've to get Gagan schpeel
right and now what did I do obviously
yeah taking the pawn makes too much
sense he would expect that yeah I don't
want my opponents to Queen after 96 and
I haven't played this game over since 91
by remember doing that now he can't do
Viswanathan and in 91 he was pretty good
Vishwanathan now he's nothing terrible
if you're falling the world rapid in
blitz don't look up a non score he's
just kidding he's not really playing
horrible
well you can't look up mvl score if you
insist I mean a lot of know what's
happened in day 2 so only day 1 okay so
now white was assuming that after a 5 I
would take his pawn
play 6e seven and he'd have counterplay
and I would fold but instead 96 and he's
got nothing
okay Shack a for his bishops pretty good
enough sex terrible King C for forcing
this and my pawns pretty good pretty
good
now pretty pretty good and he played
what move don't see resign you Bishop a3
now if you know your ad studies you will
know that I play King a1 here however if
you know my comedy you know I didn't do
that
penalize not were the usual did you did
you drug them or something what did my
comer do to you people all right so I
took obviously and even though my
opponent gets to Queen though he didn't
Queen he resigned I get to queen with
checkmate is this legal
all right is this mate all right there
you go so that was another interesting
chigorin that went into an end game very
similar to the first game now we're
going to change tack a little bit
because we're not going to break the
computer like we did the last time okay
this is one of my few draws in the
chigorin why sex all my pieces so my
cover is going to really enjoy this Kim
I sacked everything then it was a drawn
rook upon ending sorry but I tried this
is my good friend dr. Steve Feldman feed
a master medical doctor now I have a
funny story about Steve hopefully he's
not watching this because he ain't going
to like this there's a guy in Michigan
who occasionally has seizures okay not
Justin and he only has he's just when
he's playing chess he's not he's fine so
he plays chess every year or two has a
seizure stops playing so I'm playing in
a league match and then of course the
guy has the seizure because that's what
he does sort of like get on the Geico
commercials that's what he does is it
Geico or progressive I don't know is it
Geico yeah I knew cover would know
like the guy has seizures that's what he
does okay so when he has a seizure the
game always ends sometimes he wins times
he loses so that's his opponents like
whoa you win oh my god
and this one's like hey I won the guys I
think it's easier it depends whose
opponent is anyway he had a seizure so
the chess board gets thrown over he's
foaming at the mouth
okay sort of like a couple days ago at
you anyway so okay so dr. Feldman was
playing like three boards away and I
remember him like yeah like this game
was much more important the guy dying
back there
he was looking yeah yeah he might live
but look at this position I got okay so
he knew what was important even I helped
the guy and that's when you know when I
help you you're not in trouble okay so
he played rook g1 Steve and I broke my
rule because rules are made to be broken
now Lulu's been playing quite a bit of
attention and she probably noticed that
in the last two games I castlelong
kingside that's where we are now I play
g6 yes the greatest trick ever
although kingside castling is better
okay you with some crazy comment that
would be too good no by the way I think
every move is better than g6 g6 terrible
you with some crazy comment you mean is
it legal okay I take it
day yeah my comer is furious my coverage
is like who is this guy lots of this guy
yeah by the way after age four what if
you could move again
queen h5 you could have said her g5 and
saved yourself you know this is why my
camera lectures instead of you I'm not
sure there must be another reason to
okay
so g 6f for short castle Bishop g2 Queen
back now I'm threatening Knight takes d4
there's no way he'll see that king up
[ __ ]
Rick GA Queen b3 Knight takes d4 that
moves to complicated
my comer approved that's what he did I
know that's what he did you saw Queen a6
check you also see King e1 now you can
castle the other way this was a few
years ago they didn't change the rules
yet Knight f5 now do I have good comp
for a piece the answer is fries I mean
yes I got Ricky eight check I'm not
going to tell you which one I got 9
takes d4 right I'm all over you like
Oprah on self-promotion and she wasn't
even famous in 92 or was she yeah she
was okay right yeah okay
so I'm not sure if I'm all over him then
okay so Bishop takes b7 confusing
everyone rook check Bishop e3 Queen f6
computer says all zeros yeah but that's
that's what you get with a chigorin
complicated now I beat the rap on why
the chigorin is bad all of you people at
home you're like two admissions is
better than two nights hi I only have
one night now
you didn't see that coming yeah can't
complain about my other night okay so
King f1 again rook b8 hitting his Bishop
rip b1 Knight d6 Queen f5 attacking his
rook you saw it takes takes notice my
rook honey it is hanging right comer
very good covers like wait a minute he's
like just a second here so if I take his
rook he takes Knight rook would check so
I did this and we get to a draw and rook
and pawn endgame yeah but I don't have a
king king d3 rook c1 Rick c7 I could
lose that happened by the way now that
that all happened ok draw and then I
perpetual him he pretzels me
we're happy family draw agreed all
zeroes though at the end so that was a
very exciting game and when I do live
commentary here which you people at home
can't see why aren't you coming here
what's wrong with you when I do a live
commentary for us championship
Sinquefield Cup u.s. women's us junior
of the junior they can see right I think
the junior is on the Internet yeah the
other ones you can't see that okay I
talked about how when the game is really
exciting at the beginning then it Peters
out you withdraw and when it's really
boring then it gets all exciting and
time trouble so this is just such such
an instant okay now we're going to skip
way what happened edit everything
alright so this is my game with salvias
bird she's the only thing tougher than
beating him is pronouncing his name okay
his last name is ber CYS okay and he had
just come from Wheel of Fortune where he
bought a vowel and then he sold it to
the fuchsia wow I couldn't believe it
okay and we played the obvious beginning
okay now in this scheme we're going to
see a queenside castling without a queen
trade how
I remember seeing him a year or two
after this game and he explained to me
how he was crushing me
what all right so Rick g1 what did I
play last game Lulu
remember you said castles but it was a
lie what did I play do you remember yeah
yeah that's right
hopefully I improved this game yes
castles g6 terrible
next time I'll play Knight g6 because my
camera recommended it bishop c3 rogue da
e for too early which reminds me of a
funny joke except that's not a joke it
happened in real life too grand
ministers were playing one was better
than the other
and the weaker Grandmaster offered a
draw like I moved six and the guy said
it is too early
get him drawn six moves it wasn't
Nakamura and McShane obviously anyway so
then I moved 20 he's like okay offer
draw and the guy said too late all right
efore too early he's trying to beat me
the first 10 moves
I'm not chopped liver a vegetarian come
on ridiculous so Queen age 5 what am i
doing Julian this is put in at age come
on cut of my lectures more often all
right
he played f4 woohoo I'm scared well a
little scared actually
ok Queen age 2 as you recommended queen
g4 my comer approved my cover is like
queen g4 that's right alright now we
have to stop mate so now the thing is if
he doesn't meet me I'm going to take all
his pawns and meet him right so sort of
like at the end of The Hustler he's like
he's like you better kill me because if
you don't put all those little pieces
back together and so help me burn I'm
going to kill you nothing you're all the
worst but at you at home one or two of
you know the hustler so then you like
yeah no you don't you're the worst
all right you're not like Matt Larson
who got me the the blu-ray of the
hustler for some holiday I don't know
somehow I ever heard of what okay so I
might get mated but I might not and then
he's in trouble
Kings on e1d pawns hanging he's down
upon you with some crazy comment it's
not my move did not just play Knight g6
but you're right if it was my move
Knight takes d4 ah okay he played d5 now
Knight takes d4 is risky so now if my
knight moves then f5 rookie a so I'm
attacking him - yeah is it Ricky for
scary you scared my cover like I was
like I'm scared with both sides I never
seen him so interested he's like what's
happening yeah so this is actually one
reason why I like this opening now I was
accused on YouTube probably by some
super intelligent individual that I'm
the most boring player ever okay like
the Oh boring world of niels bohr that
kind of boring right
is that like boring to you is don't
think so alright this is exciting
ooh okay Chicago open open tournament
all right
he played long castle also exciting
Queen takes f2 sacrificing a piece and
he played Bishop d3 not accepting
complicated so if he takes my knight
what do I do
rip d1 Queens XD ones risky because his
rooks hanging so King takes d1 no why
not all right now I don't know Ricky for
Queen see it is made yeah probably I
just resigned what
Queen a too rugged da check after rook
da Queen d7 my comers confused very
confused he's like a little looks good
for whom white what what why what can I
take and go here haha now where work to
wherever a block slip another whoever
that is move there okay so probably
should take in my night but I would have
won anyway with some trickery and deceit
right okay so he played Bishop to d3
Queen C 5 X clam Knight be 4x clam and
for those of you who can count I'm two
pawns up and look at my two nights yes
this should be one rub g6 ha I did it
again
hurt d6 at every possible chigorin now
the idea is to checkmate them with
advantage Bishop d4 Queen C for a three
c5 now if you know the on poisson ruled
is even more legal moves here if you
don't know that saves you some hassle
yeah now you confused yet he's so mad
he's he's spirited there's other stuff
going on like the Democratic debates
going on all right who wants to try to
win a million dollars it's like the
millionaire open all you have to do is
name all five Democratic candidates on
this stage now nobody can do that I
asked the guy who is the miner he's like
what there's more than two yeah he was
like I can't believe it
alright it turns out even Donald Trump
showed up he's like yeah whatever I'll
probably never crowd anyway all right c5
Bishop c3 Knight a6 rook g3 obviously
rook here check is annoying so he
defends his bishop even though comer
would play f5 Queen a4
jackin his rook I didn't really attack
his Rick I tricked you
f5 rook check Queen a3 check Knight be
for threatening and yeah
Queen a to me so he should stop that
yeah like Queen see three checks
annoying their life stuff okay so he
took the night obviously I was like yeah
that's my man I'm threatening queen bee
to mate Knight e5 haha with your f5 and
we trade into this ending where I'm
three pawns up cover shocked yeah and
after h5 he resigned yeah cuz good
Bishop on a - I wouldn't resign but he
was fed up with it yeah
very suspicious game he was not happy
afterwards or a year later but that's
what that chigorin does it makes you
furious because you're probably winning
right away then you lose yeah
all right now my favourite game why is
it my favorite I didn't play it yeah I
didn't understand this game at all but
the computer explained it to me so now I
understand it a little
this is fight against Logan off was a
good player I got supply I've never
heard of T shen never heard of him and
it was play to the suite in Memorial and
I played Sweden what if it's the same
guy all right so they transpose okay
Rick g1 and once I played g6 once I
castled this guy castled don't blink by
the way the game ends really soon
games almost over no serious ok f4 rook
e8 Bishop g2 Queen F I never play Queen
f5 never bishop c3 Knight g6 my comer
recommended queen bee 1 I now the game
is 2000% tactics
and unfortunately white missed
everything so the game ended in like two
moves all right so what black point the
obvious tactic Queens except for looks
good and then white played King f1
threatening pawn takes Queen with
advantage rook takes c3 although we're
not done
Queens IG's b7
the bike comer resigns with both colors
not hold on it took me hours with a
computer understand this game not as
positions hard
actually queen b1 was it a bad move
so this is why I like the chick Orion
because I figure better player will
probably win and I hope I'm the better
player which isn't always the case but
you get positions where you're not
suffering both sides are suffering
that's what should happen in chess yeah
you're the best player in your chair
yeah when he's right don't raise your
hand just say wow that was good
you were just agreeing okay rugby a
queen c6 Queen f5
some people think queen d3 is made here
yeah yeah that's also good this Queen b1
check is that good
okay so queen b1 check rugby 1 check
Queen d3 mate that's a lot of threats
why play the computer recommended move
you're right except you don't know your
rotation
otherwise you're right well no you're
close keep going yeah there you go
that's what you meant pretend you minute
Bishop to e4 if I take them on material
a meeting you yeah I mean that's giving
up without a fight
Bishop g5 fight fight fight fight
draw I'll then play the winning move
nice night h4 notice black black white
can play King g2 in many positions
because the white bishop isn't on g2 I'm
serious but now he can't
so now Queen g3 is made again right my
comer gay now white played a move
recommended by Mike comer now clause
exactly not and now much to the chagrin
of you at home because you had to watch
this lecture and all of you here because
you don't know the right answer and to
white black made the best move shocking
everybody what who who what move are you
just raising up with everybody again
King AJ right if you play Queen takes f7
then it's hard to play Queen d3 check or
Queen h3 check and King takes allows all
kinds of trickery and deceit King AJ and
he has nothing
even though White's a piece up it's plus
eight billion for black it actually nots
has made the computer and white resigned
and white was the higher rated player
but it was too complicated for him right
because the this openings complicated
White's King is on e1 he rarely castles
in the game where he Castle to Castle
queenside against me and why can castle
either way and there's a lot of tactics
and tricks now white does score well but
I didn't show you those games and this
may explain why more as a [ __ ] rating
is now zero may he played in the blitz I
got like zero terrible well more is a
[ __ ] was one of the leading exponents
of this opening he keeps losing so yeah
does it play any more more is a [ __ ]
always plays that you're going yeah they
take you wrote a book on the chigorin
right back me up